hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a 2015 american drama and
fantasy movie called goosebumps
the movie begins with zach cooper and
his mother gail who just moved to
madison delaware after his father passed
away to start a new life
upon arriving at their new house zach
feels like someone is spying on him from
the house next door he ignores the
mysterious guy and walks into the house
where his aunt lorraine suddenly appears
and greets them
she also gives zach a bedazzled hat as a
welcome gift to the town
he reluctantly wears it as his mom
forces him to do so
when zack is unloading the boxes from
the car a teenager from the house next
door named hannah greets him from the
window
however her rude dad suddenly intervenes
and warns zach to stay away from his
daughter for no reason
gail accidentally picks up an old
picture of his husband from the box
which makes zack reminiscing sweet
memories with his father the next day
zak attends high school where his mother
surprisingly will be the new vice
principal of the school
all students gather at the basketball
court to welcome her where zach meets
his first friend champ
at the same time gail gives an opening
speech but it seems like the students
don't feel happy about her presence
back at his new house zach is taking out
the trash when hannah startles him by
sneaking in from the broken fence
he asks her about fun places in the town
thus she guides him to the woods across
the street
they eventually arrive at an abandoned
amusement park where the pair climb the
ferris wheel and sit on one of the carts
with a nice view of the town
when they arrive home hannah's father
confronts zack and gives him a final
warning or something bad will happen
still that evening zack overhears hannah
arguing with her dad who prohibits her
from seeing zach again
from a distance it seems like the father
loses control and hannah suddenly
screams which makes zack panic and
immediately runs to hannah's house
the father tells the boy not to
interfere with their family business and
shuts the door afterwards
afraid that hannah might be in trouble
zach calls 9-1-1
two rookie officers stephen brooks show
up with gail and zach and question the
father
he claims that he lives there alone at
the moment as hannah just flew to london
the day earlier
suddenly they hear another scream which
turns out to be coming from a movie
as no proof of domestic violence is
found the officers leave the house while
warned zack about the penalty for filing
a false report
gail has to chaperone the dance at
school and asks lorraine to take care of
zack
realizing that the argument is still
happening zack asks for champ's help who
is coincidentally passing by to
accompany him after he disguised as a
cop and orders hannah's father to go to
the police station by phone
as soon as the father drives away they
sneak into the house through the
basement full of bear traps and go
upstairs
the two come across a bookcase filled
with locked manuscripts of old goosebump
stories all of which were written by a
man called r.l stein zach discovers a
key and unlocks one of the books the
abominable snowman of pasadena
soon after hannah confronts them and
learns that they have unlocked a book
zack accidentally opens the book
summoning an enormous abominable snowman
into the room champ drops the lamp which
catches the beast's attention
it destroys the bookcase while running
towards champ
luckily he is rescued by zack and the
beast escapes
hannah grabs the book in the trio chase
after the snowman
meanwhile one of the manuscripts unlocks
by itself
hannah champ and zach follow the beast
to a skating rink where the snowman
suddenly appears from the scoreboard
with a candy vending machine
the monster spots them just before
hannah prepares to suck it back into the
book and attacks them
zack manages to toss the book out of the
arena to prevent the snowman getting the
book
it eventually corners them and tries to
destroy the glass but hannah's father
appears from behind and sucks the beast
back into the book
he then furiously orders the teenagers
to get into the car
on their way zach and champ eventually
realized that hannah's father is
actually r.l stein the author of the
goosebumps stories who disappeared a
long time ago
upon arrival stein orders the boys to
return home while he starts packing his
stuff to move to another town again
however they insist on staying in urge
stein to explain what is actually
happening
he reveals that he created his own
friends to terrorize his neighborhood
since he was not allowed to leave the
house and they bullied him for that he
adds that one day the creatures from the
books became real this he had to lock
them
stein walks to the bookcase to gather
all the books but he then finds out that
one of the evilest creatures slappy has
leapt off from the book
he burns his own book so that stein
cannot put him back into custody again
slappy takes all the books and unleashes
several horrifying creatures along the
way which haunt the entire town because
of the invasion the town's communication
has been brought down on the other hand
stein and the teenagers run to the
kitchen only to find a horde of
murderous dwarfs that are ready to
attack them they attempt to smash the
dwarfs into pieces but they are then
overwhelmed when the dwarfs keep putting
their pieces back together forcing them
to flee to the basement and escape from
the house stein and the others find all
the books have been burned to prevent
the creatures being sucked back
back to slappy he brings two aliens to
the police station where they freeze the
rookie officers with their fancy weapons
stein and the teenagers arrive at the
center of the town where the creatures
indeed caused a total mess
zach suggests stein writes a new
manuscript that tells a story to capture
all the creatures stein initially
refuses and underestimates zack's idea
but he then realizes that there is no
other way to save the town
before that they drive to zack's high
school where stein's magical typewriter
is being hidden on their way they were
confronted by an invisible creature
called invisible boy
luckily they still managed to kick him
out of the car
they also come across a giant praying
mantis that attempts to attack them
the car eventually rolls over and the
mantis crushes the empty car
they retreat into the supermarket where
they find a wild werewolf is craving for
meat as usual champ makes some noises
causing the monster to notice them and
start chasing them
stein sprays a bottle of perfume to his
body to cover his scent but it doesn't
work
the beast goes after the humans who
manage to escape through the
supermarket's back door but the monster
easily breaks the door and corners them
until lorraine arrives and hits the
werewolf with her car
zach commands lorraine to report the
situation to the police while the group
continues to head towards the high
school through a shortcut
lorraine runs into the police station
and finds no one
suddenly slappy shows up and gets her
frozen as well
while passing through the cemetery the
moonlight shines on hannah revealing
that hannah is actually not real
zak realizes that but speaks nothing to
her
suddenly ghouls and zombies rise from
the grave and start terrorizing them
they managed to run away from the
cemetery and lock the creatures
they make it to the school and zack
immediately confronts stein about hannah
he admits that hannah is one of his
creations and both men are afraid of
losing her they find the typewriter and
stein begins writing while the teenagers
buy him some time
they arrive at the hall where the dance
takes place and zack climbs on stage to
warn everyone about the emerging
monsters
but no one believes him and they even
laugh at him until the giant mantis
breaks through the ceiling and captures
a teacher
everyone starts running for their life
and seals off the exit door for safety
while slappy keeps unleashing more and
more creatures
after the army is formed slappy gives
the monsters a mission which is to get
rid of stein
the creatures break into the creature
and start attacking the students and the
school staff
the werewolf gets into the school
corridor and almost attacks champs crush
until the hero shows up and bites the
werewolf with his silver filings
his crush is impressed with champ's
bravery and rewards him with a kiss on
the lips meanwhile slappy eventually
locates stein and breaks his fingers
before he can finish the story
zach and hannah grab the typewriter and
are attacked by a murderous plant while
running through the corridor
the students and the staff gather at the
basketball court while the monsters are
trying to break in
realizing that the creatures are chasing
after stein zak comes up with an idea to
lure the creatures out of the school
with the decoy school bus and use
explosives from the chem lab to blow out
the monsters and buy some time for them
stein and the teenagers come back to the
abandoned amusement park and decide to
hide in the house of mirrors
not long after slappy follows them into
the fun house and chastises stein for
locking him up in the book
he then unleashes the blob that ate
everyone
stein hands over the book pages and
handwriting to zach so that he can
finish the final line just before he
gets caught by the slimy monster
the teenagers climb the ferris wheel and
zack eventually manages to finish the
story as the monsters crawl toward them
the giant mantis attacks the ferris
wheel causing it to break and roll
through the woods
the teenagers arrive at an open space
and hannah orders zach to open the book
he initially refuses because that means
that he will lose hannah too and he is
not ready for that turns out that hannah
has known the truth about her too and
she finally opens the book for him
creating a huge portal that pulls all
the monsters back into the book
slappy holds on to stein for a while
until he kicks the evil creature and it
flies back into the book
finally hannah who turns into blue
transparent form gives the last kiss to
zach before slowly getting pulled back
to the book
after that the town is recovering from
the massive damage caused by the
creatures and the students returned to
the school
stein also becomes the new english
teacher at zack school after class stein
gives a surprise to zack by bringing
hannah back to life
he then burns the manuscript so that the
couple can stay together
the new teacher then goes over to check
on his magical typewriter turns out that
the invisible boy was not sucked back
into the book and he starts typing a
manuscript titled the invisible boy's
revenge
the creature greets stein as he screams
in fear
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching